[Applaudissements]
pense à ta veine pense à mon chagrin si
tu étais reine et moi
baladin je sais quand bien même j'aurai
la M peine pour toi ma charmante
faudrait que je chante j'aurai le
dimanche l'ermine à la Manche qu'il vend
tout qu'il neige tous les
privilèges une vie serine des nuit sans
chagrin si tu es t reine et moi
baladin pense à ta veine pense à mon
chagrin si tu estais reine et moi
baladin pour quelques poème pour quel
que je t'aime fini le Carême qui durait
toujours ad Dieu la famine j'aurai bonne
mine et P ta d me sont pesant d'amour et
si ça me gêne le fa de mes chaînes qui
mettrait ma reine un peu de
velour pense à ta veine pense à mon
chagrin si tu étais reine et moi
baladin au fond de ta Bastille tu
mettrais les filles qui ont su m'aimer
ou qui m'aimeront au prond tes galères
ignorance terre bogant vers l'enfer mes
vieux
compagnons adieu les balades finis les
obades et mon cœur nomade serait en
prison
pense à ta veine pense à mon chagrin si
tu es t reine et moi
baladin au bout de ma laisse qui
raillant sans cesse j'aurai les caresses
que l'on donne au chiens je sais qu'à
tout prendre plutôt que me perdre tu me
ferais pendre et tu ferais bien parce
que je préfère cordes ou galèr au près
de mes frères tous les
Baladins mais tu as pas eu de veine ne
j'auris pas de chagrin car tu nes pas
reine et je suis baladin et je suis
baladin et je
suis